yo what up it's your boy Bryson tiller
check me out on the bootleg cab podcast
show special guest I've interviewed him
before but never on camera
by the way shout out to Bryson tiller
he's in the building man yes sir yes sir
the legend okay I gotta say man um why
are you doing stuff on camera now
because before you were not doing camera
stuff like I feel like it was kind of
like when you first came out like the
Trap Soul days you kind of were keeping
a mysterious profile yeah I remember I
interviewed you on the bus it was like
No cameras and that was kind of like the
thing where it's like yo
we we hear the interviews like but
Bryson you're kind of very like
you kind of you were you still you're
pretty low-key dude in general right
yeah and I was just new to it I didn't
want to you know be all over the
Internet you know what I mean it was
just like a thing for me I just was just
very new to everything so I was just
kind of like trying to take my time not
just be rushed into it you know that's
fair do you feel like um you're kind of
like
the music industry is a very finicky
business it's kind of like even just
just the entertainment industry in
general you kind of Splash onto the
scene in such a meteoric way
and so fast
um was it like hard to adjust to it in
such a quick way you think that that's
yeah absolutely yeah it was a lot a lot
to adjust to like
it was like I always tell who do I give
this analogy to but I say it all the
time it's like taking a
a lion that was raised in inside the
house and then just put them in a jungle
you know what I'm saying for the last
time he's still lying but you know it's
just like weird out here you know yeah
that was going on 100 man a hunt for
food yeah nah for sure I think like um I
think I think back to like when I first
met you I think um
I think that was when did trapsil come
out 2015-14 15 15. yeah man by the way
those Nike dad hats man they owe you a
check for those damn man Nike
pun intended by the way you had those
Nike dad hats popping yeah it was crazy
did you notice like when you were
wearing that hat like everyone started
wearing the Nike like just the Vintage
like Nike almost like the Tiger Woods
hat kind of low-key you know took a
while for me to realize and then I
started noticing yeah yeah everybody
that everybody's wearing the dead at you
definitely yeah you were I would say you
were kind of the originator of dad hats
in Hip Hop Loki yeah I would say I
definitely am you are 100 yeah yeah but
it's on a round of applause everybody in
here
we are wearing dad hats because of pen
Griffey you know what I'm saying
um yeah man uh what a time though man I
do feel like you know we got to give you
your flowers for being somebody who
really kind of revolutionized the genre
and kind of created your own genre
within r b
um
and I feel like nowadays we really hear
your influence on music in general
um do you feel like uh maybe you don't
get enough flowers in terms of just kind
of
bringing a new
genre into I guess a sub genre of music
into r b
um
I mean I've I've seen a lot of people
say trap soul and but that but don't
mention my name you know what I'm saying
or I see people
talk about Kentucky and don't mention my
name which is crazy it's nuts well
that's crazy as well right yeah yeah
don't ever do it again don't let it
happen again right yeah so uh nah but
it's all good though it's all up yeah
now that uh obviously Kentucky's
obviously a thing now but when you came
out it was not a thing it was not yeah
when we had people from you know Nappy
Roots Nappy Roots player static major ah
yeah you know
but I just mean in terms of like being
on the Forefront like you were like like
on a Star level it was just you yeah now
you got estg you got Jack Harlow we do
you and Jack have been locked in for a
long time
um what is it like now just to see like
the home state really kind of
you know have some real representation
um when for a while you were kind of
standing on the mountain by yourself
man I was just saying this earlier this
like it's a relief you know it was a
person felt like it was all lives on me
you know now I knew that sometimes I
knew at some point that like somebody
would come up out of the city like it's
crazy I low-key predicted um estg Jack
came out of nowhere but uh you know I
was like man it's only a matter of time
before we get like a street artist you
know you know somebody who's like
rapping to the streets from Louisville
um and then next thing you know the STG
comes out and I was just like yeah no
it's a guy yeah sure so uh shout out to
Louisville uh
for people who uh have never been it is
a rabid college town right yeah I would
say yeah the Cardinals Cardinals
basketball pretty much
how crazy is the Rivalry between the
Cardinals and the Wildcats uh I would
say I would say it's pretty crazy I I I
was never like tuned into the sports
like that I was in the crib all the time
now some Batman and [ __ ] like just
playing video games and that was pretty
much it music is what pulled me outside
if anything
um but uh
but yeah as far as the the Rivalry goes
it would be a thing like it's a question
like you know I mean like Who Who Are
You repping you know cards or you know
the wildcats wildcats you know for me it
was the Wildcats for sure oh you're a
Kentucky Wildcats guy yeah yeah just
like Drake who's obviously not from
there yeah yeah I watched the two uh I
watched the year whenever um John Wall
Eric Bledsoe DeMarcus Cousins yeah that
was a crazy team yeah it was nuts I like
watched every game I like weird [ __ ]
like that like anomalies like they won
every game I like stuff like that yeah
they had like so many NBA I mean it just
there was like a seven or eight year run
where just like every every draft there
was like a top three guy coming from
Kentucky and that year was insane yeah
that was a wild year even like uh what
was the what's the enes Kanter I think
might have been on uh that team I think
he was on that team as well uh or what
do they call him now he and his freedom
I don't know
um talk about well first of all you
mentioned video games you uh during the
pandemic uh we got to see you on Twitch
a lot oh yeah you was gaming pretty
heavy I was getting heavy yeah was it
Apex Legends you were playing it's still
Apex that's still see you know that's
like for people who don't know man Apex
Legends is kind of like the the the
stepchild of the
the Video Game World because we always
hear about Call of Duty right oh yeah
Modern Warfare everybody's on [ __ ]
Modern Warfare and then you hear about I
mean like the overhype [ __ ] you know I
mean it's just like and then there's
like fortnite which is GTA that's 2K and
that's Cod and now if anything people
like mention fortnite or whatever you
know what I'm saying but those are like
the main games that people know but like
Apex is on the come up on the rise and
people don't even realize that like Apex
are just a better game you think it's
better than all those oh I wouldn't say
all the other games
um my producer that's all he [ __ ]
does then Cod absolutely he played
another place who's your man
great okay race man in the building man
now she's a a legend that you could
select in the game oh okay so she wanted
the OG Legends so when you play Apex
Legends you it's not do you build your
own character no no you don't you just
select from a roster of Legends that
they have yeah and if anything you can
put their own skin but they all got
their own different abilities like my
favorite who's yours mine is Mirage so
basically like I can like just send a
decoy and I have one Bryson tiller right
here and then I just walk to the
bathroom while you're interviewing that
person I was about to say do you kind of
wish you had that in real I do yes like
I don't want to do all this [ __ ] man
just like let's send the [ __ ] decoy
out there yeah back in the day MF Doom
used to do that you know what MF Doom is
oh yeah so MF Doom he because he he
wears a mask yeah so he had a guy who
was built similar to him that would go
out there and perform some of his shows
oh wow under the mask and just lip sync
and I think I did that maybe one time
with Swan because there's one point
where people couldn't tell us apart yeah
not for a concert at all he wouldn't
survive out there
but when it came to like walking to a
club or something like I think we had to
use them as a decoy but wait wait wait
wait wait wait yeah my best friend swine
like you know I mean he had uh he had to
go like when he was my dude you had a
club walkthrough booked no no no no no
no it was like I was I we had to get out
of the club or something it was just too
crazy so I had to like so you had kind
of like yo had the security surround him
yeah and I thought you were like yo my
guy pulled up to the club he got the
back end and he did don't and he got the
[ __ ] up out of there that sounds like
some Akon boost [ __ ] yeah well I mean
yeah but you know Akon's brother really
like you you know I'm sure in like
before the internet yeah before like
Instagram I could see that I could see
people pulling that type of [ __ ] off
nowadays not happening I don't think so
it's it's it's a little too everyone
everything's just so trans uh
transparent what up you always stop in
the interview real quick to tell you
about our good friends at my bookie
we're live in my room right now in Las
Vegas and if you're not in Las Vegas
like me and you want to gamble on Sports
and the easiest most convenient way you
want to get that money man listen NFL
season we got college football we got
NBA going stupid right now all you got
to do is sign up right now at my bookie
using the promo code bootleg and they
will match your first deposit up to a
thousand dollars that's right whatever
you deposit up two thousand dollars
they're gonna match that they're gonna
give you free money to gamble with so
what the [ __ ] are you doing inflation is
crazy everybody can use some extra money
they're gonna give you some free money
to play with if you make your first
deposit using that promo code bootleg up
to a thousand dollars they're gonna
match it uh I'm gonna tell you what this
weekend
Cardinals versus Niners Monday Night
Football Mexico City
I don't like my Cardinals go heavy on
them Niners all right that's all that's
my bet for the week all right let me
know what you gotta hit me on Instagram
and all that don't forget to sign up and
get this money with me at my bookie all
right go to my bookie right now stream
games bet on them you could live bet
them you could do the props and of
course they got the live casino all that
mybookie promo code bootleg sign up
right now and they're gonna match your
money up to a thousand dollars let's get
back to the interview what isn't going
on right now obviously you've been you
dropped the uh the the Weight remix
which by the way genius I'm glad
somebody did that man I'm just the Yin
Yang Twins don't get enough love man
twins man they put up to the shoot happy
smiling yeah you know what I mean it was
super great guys and good good spirits
man and just classic records yeah
exactly man and um yeah now that was
dope we uh we dropped that song we were
sitting on it for a while but uh wanted
to just kind of spark and start the
album process and kind of shake up
anybody's expectations of what oh what's
to come yeah instead to putting
something out there it's like what
people are used to hearing from me you
know what I'm saying we got a lot more
records like that too so and then
obviously uh you have the uh this Diddy
record that's going crazy which is
really absurd I mean what's really your
record you know what I'm saying shout
out to Diddy this is exactly producing a
great out in my hair right now yeah man
yeah so how does that happen does he
like do you does that song exist already
and then did he hears it and it's like
yo it existed already it actually got
leaked on um
um on YouTube I said to my little
brother he sent it to the wrong people
they say you know it's on YouTube people
like yo your song leaked and I was
pissed about I was angry I didn't talk
to my little brother for months and um I
remember finally I was just like all
right I'm gonna go check I'm gonna go
see what's going on see if people even
like this song I go on there and I read
the comments and everybody's just
sharing about sharing these stories
about how they need to move on and I
relate to this song so much I was like
oh that's dope and then um fast forward
again to the Future I'm in LA and I get
a call from Diddy and he's like come
work on the album I get out there I see
my song on the song title on the dry
erase board so I was just like is that
my song and um he plays the song
actually he tells me a similar shares a
similar story like everything that I've
seen in the comments so I was right this
is wild like yeah absolutely so he just
heard the leaked version yeah and just
decided and he to put it on the
Whiteboard for his album yeah that's
just some ditty [ __ ] right hey man I'm
rocking with it I would do this I would
do the same thing if I heard something
that nobody really heard and I feel like
the world needed to hear yeah and you
know shout out to Diddy for believing in
it yeah no it's great record the remix
is dope uh you guys did I was at the
iHeart festival and you came out oh yeah
shout out to Diddy too like uh his
performance at iron Festival was amazing
but it also made me realize that I'm not
the only person who's out of shape and
not for real yo Diddy had a dude who
kept bringing out a cup of water with a
straw in between songs it was amazing I
was like if I was a [ __ ] famous if I
was Diddy I would have the same thing if
I'm like performing I'm like I need my
water cup guy to come out and and you
know shout out to Diddy
um yeah no uh it's still I think you
know
um
what did he like he's probably him and
Khaled I I want to see what this album
sounds like because I feel like he's
kind of doing his version of what
Calvin's been doing but he's ditty so
it's just totally different and it's r b
it's r b his r b Lover he ain't dead or
he said it is dead but he's trying to
bring it back you know right yeah you
think he's dead I'm glad he said that
you know I think it's uh I mean I'm not
I'm not saying that I agree with him but
I'm just saying I'm glad he said that
because I feel like people out there who
either agree or disagree or like it
created a conversation about the genre
however you feel about it right yeah and
it uh you know it's just gonna make
things better I think you know when I
said hip-hop was dead now look at hip
hop 100 now that's the biggest [ __ ] so
it's like this is true this is true
um your new album how would you describe
it it's uh just sonically compared to
you know something else other stuff
um sonically I would say uh
hmm it's just very different man we just
try and I just explore a lot of new
worlds places that I've never really
been before and like well maybe some
places I tried to go before and I wasn't
too comfortable in those spaces like for
example some like run me dry like I had
a song called rummy drop one of my
second album and uh I wasn't really I
was nervous about doing a song like that
um now I have a song that's kind of like
that but um you know I'm a lot more
confident in that space and you know you
can just tell you can hear it you can
feel it so there's a lot of confidence
throughout this throughout this album
and uh yeah
do you feel like because I feel like Nas
went through this with Illmatic 50 went
through it with get rich or die trying
where like you put out an album like
trap soul and like people just want
another one of those yeah that's the
worst right and because that happened
with nas I mean like if you look back to
NASA's second album It Was Written it's
a [ __ ] perfect project in my opinion
but when it first came out people were
like yo this ain't Illmatic what the
[ __ ] is this you know what I'm saying do
you feel like
is that a gift the gift in the cursed
part of having a project like trap soul
and especially it's your first project
right it just made it even more right
yeah crazy
um
the way I see it now is I'm just like
man it's it's there for you to to listen
to it because I can listen to it yeah
Jay-Z said it best like Nick can I say
what you want [ __ ] want my old [ __ ]
about my old album yeah simple as that
like you want if you want that go get it
Tyler Creator said something like a two
he said something along the lines of
like yo go get it from the source while
I get the the you know the reproduced
version or whatever like you know what I
mean it's pure over here so just go
listen to that you know what I mean and
if your favorite artist or whoever it is
that you support and ain't putting out
anything else like that then should I
guess go find another artist to listen
to yes yeah I also take two like you got
to grow man like at the end of the day
right like you said you've seen places
because you didn't see before you
recorded your first album so you wanna
you've lived a lot of life
yeah I mean I have 100
um yo talk to me about your verse on uh
wild thoughts which is one of like it's
probably my favorite as top three or
four calorie record for me it's a
[ __ ] smash obviously you and Riri
going back and forth your verse though
is like the verse that like if you're
mixing on the air
like you have to play the like your
verse is the verse to play really my
verse always gets cut out every time no
but that's because people are the DJs
are lazy the DJs that know like you
gotta kind of cut ahead into the record
and play The Bryson brush because I feel
like your verse is the quotables like
shout out to you man for for playing
well I know a lot of DJs who play that's
the version I feel like you gotta you
kind of like have the version where
actually there's like in DJ pools
there's versions of that record where
it's just the hook
and then your verse and then the hook
and then it's you know for for DJs yeah
interesting you're not aware about this
about your own verse that it's like a
thing oh yeah not classic first man it
was uh it was interesting for sure I
thank you but um I just wish
I wish I could have went uh differently
but hey man how could it have gone
differently I just wish I mean because
uh I just needed I wanted to like you
know get Rihanna's energy I didn't get
to hear what she did well I heard it
through a FaceTime call but like I
wanted to hear it yeah so what was the
process of that record like it was party
next door who wrote the song okay party
next uh I went to college place we had
dinner
um invites me to the studio I always
tell them it's like bro you don't never
have to give me a whole spiel about a
song like you just played a song and
they're like let's go but he always
gives me this whole like he's like yeah
yo don't let kids start selling cars
it's over nah for real yeah so then he
played this song and I was just like I'm
honestly bro you could just you didn't
have to say nothing like this is
obviously a smash you know what I'm
saying thank you for even wanting to
include me you said you wanna put who on
it Rihanna oh yeah definitely thank you
um but he wanted he was like yo we need
the verse tonight though so I'm like and
I was just like I I mean but ain't she
gonna have to I'm gonna have to pitch it
up so you know I mean Rihanna sings in a
higher octave he was like now we just
need tonight and I'll just like all
right cool so I did the verse but you
know when I'm writing the verse to like
that matching party's energy you know I
mean it's kind of hard to like imagine
what's going on like I would have just
liked to do a little bit more vocals you
know what I mean probably would have
changed a couple lyrics man yeah I just
thought I was you know a song called
wild thoughts I'm gonna just say the
wildest [ __ ] that I can think of wildest
the wildest thoughts you know that's
fair yeah and then in that era it could
have been about wild thoughts as well
wild thoughts yeah that was like when
everybody was saying the word oh yeah
yeah they still say that word yeah is
that is that still you know thoughts
maybe not as much but it's definitely
definitely a word it's in my vocabulary
shout out to the thoughties
out there yeah I mean what up we gotta
stop the interview real quick we're live
in Vegas right now uh listen fellas if
you're watching this and you need a
little extra pep in your step you know
what step I'm talking about I'm talking
about that dick step damn it all right
if you need some help with that Dickie
or uh paluchu is here to save the day
that's right same exact ingredient as
Viagra and Seattle us but here's the
catch no awkward doctor's appointments
it comes straight to your door in a
chewable form very discreet packaging
very discreet billing uh you don't have
to go to a random waiting room while you
wait to get your dick pills from the
doctor it's an embarrassing situation no
with Bluetooth all you do is go to
bluetooth.com right now sign up with the
promo code bootleg that's the most
important part when you sign up with
bootleg at bluetooth.com you get your
first month for free you just got to pay
five dollars shipping that's right you
go to Bluetooth you get the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis and
that blue True Form your dick is uh on
an all-time high I mean this thing is
[ __ ] booming and then on the other
end they just dropped their new mint
chewable which has the same active
ingredients as Levitra all right which
is even stronger so if you really need
some help in the dick Department
Bluetooth got you all right go get a
free month fellas I don't care if you're
not even dealing with any dick problems
maybe you just want to impress somebody
you're about to [ __ ] Hammer all right
go to Bluetooth get your first month for
free right now delivered right to your
doorstep using that promo code bootleg
go do that and let's get back to the
interview what's now when are you
getting this uh when are we getting the
album
um man I was trying to you know we was
trying to get it out this year but uh
with samples and stuff you know how that
goes yeah and it's like really if you
don't get it out by like next Friday
there's no point I mean the music
industry shuts down right you guys are
on vacation
it's it's really kind of hard to put out
Mount December exactly and get like the
full impact that you want it to have you
know so uh you know top top of 20 to
February so I'm like uh probably
February yeah I'm like people come back
from vacation like January 6th oh yeah
yeah we'll see so February we'll see I'm
open to either all right January
February March it'll be February or more
April I don't know about January
January's also still kind of shaky
everyone's coming back from vacation you
know the music industry is we're letting
people behind the curtain a little here
yeah yeah
um are you are you like for you man like
what is motivating like your creative
process like what inspires you in 2022
is it your son is it
just like being a fan of other music
like what inspires you like when you get
into the booth you have an idea like
what is the main inspiration for you
musically nowadays these days
main inspiration for me man I don't know
man I'm just so excited to just give
people experiences like something that
they can like attach to a memory that
they have going on in life like that's
kind of what I'm really what I really
care about right now just giving them
one song just like you know if you
listen to my album I just want one song
for you to just take and just for you to
live with you know I mean for you to be
able to like I said attach certain
memories to it like oh I was at this
place or I was with this girl or you
know I mean that's all I care about
right now um I've been listening to a
lot of different music that's inspiring
me um Steve lacy one of the one of my
favorites you know the new Drake 21
Savage album amazing I love that album
um uh it's a lot of dope stuff what's
your album of the year my album of the
year yeah
just give me three of them how about
that so you know I mean I'll probably
say Steve Lacy just because you know I
love Melody yeah and um and then I would
say to Drake 21 her loss for sure really
already you're gonna put her loss up
there that fast yeah you're gonna let it
marinate a little bit oh I don't need to
I just heard I heard it and I just knew
it was the best meme action of the year
that too like so many different reasons
my son who's [ __ ] eight years old
not listen to the album once sings that
part yeah because he'd be on Tick-Tock
and [ __ ] yeah YouTube and I'm like bro
how do you know this that's good he's
like Drake zesty Dad
hey yo I'm like what that's crazy is
that that video game clip where someone
created Dragon yeah what's the average
of Drake's walking yeah that [ __ ] is
hilarious but the album's classic though
I love it no it's a great album and I
think um
Drake went in man that spin about you
record is so hard oh my God they both
snapped I I prefer this over I think
this is my favorite Drake project since
uh
if you're reading this probably since if
you're reading this it's too late that's
me too yeah yeah same I always feel like
when I listen to a Drake album I'm
always wanting more but I feel like I
listen to this and I'm very I love 21
Savage so I just knew I was like yo this
is going to be the Drake album I love I
just have there's no way him and 21
Savage makes him whack [ __ ] it's just
not I was so right I was like me and
swallow in the studio just like ready
for it to drop soon as it drop press
play you got a relationship with Drake
yeah how's that cool nice guy cool guy
he owes me fifty thousand dollars fifty
thousand for what
we were hanging out at Harriet's at the
bar I was with Freddie Gibbs and
this was uh two years ago
when the sun's made it to the finals
shots of them Phoenix Suns
and Drake bet me
50 I said 50 000 was the bet uh uh
whether or not the Suns or The Warriors
would make it further that year this was
like maybe three three fourths of the
way through the season I got witnesses
credible Witnesses
uh and uh yeah man just [ __ ] no way
to get a hold of Drake you know I don't
have his [ __ ] number I've dm'd him
like hey what's up with my bread bruh
yeah I mean damn I'm never gonna get my
money so when like he he made that 2K
bet on Twitch the other day with 21
Savage I'm like good luck ever getting
that money
I feel like he has a problem gambling
too
gamble a lot me no I don't gamble no no
no no he had smart no I don't gamble oh
maybe on Mario Kart or something like
that you gamble Mario Smash Bros yeah I
will are you excited for Super Nintendo
land at Universal coming yeah I'm
excited to see what they do I would
rather go to like that I think they're
doing one I think they have one already
over in like Tokyo or something like
that'd be where you'd want to go that's
where I want to go because if you go to
Tokyo I'm not answer your question no
because actually now I think about it
because it's going to be so
everybody's going to be there so I'll
probably have to wait
maybe I can rent out rent it out for
like one day or something yeah you're
rich uh but you get a VIP tour you know
yeah I went to Halloween Horror Nights
uh you ever been there no I never have
so the weekend had his own haunted house
oh for real yeah like he was like the
main Universal Studios Halloween Horror
Nights this year was like based around
the weekend that's crazy and his haunted
house was the best one I expected it to
be kind of
what's scary about the weekend there's
some wild [ __ ] going on in there I wish
I saw it's like being on a [ __ ] up
mushroom trip while listening to his
album it's pretty crazy you ever do
mushrooms nah never no okay we has done
some crazy things to me like I smoke
weed and then like I've been in like a
weird space in my head mentor and I just
sometimes I thought I was gonna die like
for us I was like I don't even want to
try any other drug that's stronger than
that you smoked weed and and um I think
it was like some salvio or some
synthetic weed or something one time
were you smoking Spice from a smoke shop
nah it was uh I don't know what was
going on no no it ain't it ain't that oh
it was something but it had me it really
had me just tripping so and then I did
the dabs one time dabs are crazy like
music sounded so horrible I didn't want
to hear nothing like every time I heard
a song I was like yo please turn this
off like yeah it just sounded like nails
uh a dab will melt your face off yeah I
couldn't stop coughing the worst [ __ ]
though is yeah yeah it like it hits you
differently it's crazy but the worst
[ __ ] is if you eat too much Edibles oh
yeah I did that one time I was working
at UPS it was wild
how was UPS EPS what was your UPS is
hiring shout out to Biggie you know how
was that for you oh we're you know the
seasonal job regular job I was working
in a part-time throughout the year I
worked there for two years I enjoyed it
you know what I mean
um I like stacking the boxes up you know
what I mean I was just working in the
factory truck loading the truck loading
the trucks up just all the way you were
always wondering as somebody who may or
may not have put wheat in the mail and
sent it out
um to the UPS guys like if did you ever
find any like packs nah never but was it
like a thing where like maybe like you
guys would talk like hey if if a box
opens up and it's some weed we could
just take it I probably would have I
ain't gonna lie because that's a thing
right if you send like pounds of weed in
the mail allegedly that if like if you
send it through UPS or FedEx it's not
the federal government the drivers would
take that [ __ ] because what are you
gonna do you're not gonna call them
right exactly money too I think right
money too yeah yeah yeah we've had some
some situation like outside of UPS any
other crazy jobs you've uh you've had
before you were uh Penn Griffey crazy
jobs not really I worked them for a
moving company that was like my first
time like being in like expensive houses
that was really cool getting like 100
tips and whatnot yeah it's just
inspirational too it was I was just like
dang all these houses in Kentucky I
didn't even know we had this no yeah I
used to go park in front of houses like
I me and my uh you know somebody I used
to [ __ ] with we used to drive around the
um there's an area in Scottsdale called
the Biltmore we used to school look at
the mansions and [ __ ] and be like one
day yeah me and my me and Swan used to
do that all the time man yeah just do
that and then you get chased out by
security like what are you doing looking
at our house like I'm just just trying
to get inspired you dick yeah it's not
for real hey what up y'all bootleg cab
got to stop the interview to tell you
about our newest sponsor man shout out
to the homies at hardean Las Vegas
that's right the number one dispensary
in the whole state of Nevada let alone
in the whole [ __ ] country so many
choices of Premium cannabis ladies and
gentlemen it is like how can I put this
you walk into it you go to hardine in
Las Vegas
when you're on vacation when you're out
there tricking off whatever you're doing
stop off at hardean tell them I sent you
be like yo bootleg Kev sent me they're
gonna take care of you at Jardin when I
say selection I mean selection of the
best premium cannabis in the world the
best dispensary there's a reason why
Jardine is world famous follow them
right now Harding underscore Las Vegas
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
that's
j-a-r-d-i-n underscore Las Vegas when
you're in Vegas you have to pull up to
hardine tell them I sent you and get
high off your [ __ ] face I don't even
know what that means how do you get high
off of your face whatever melt your
[ __ ] face off with some of that good
hard Dean y'all go follow one more time
that's Hardy in underscore Las Vegas
let's get back to the interview
so new album coming in hopefully by
February March
something like April
um any other features coming soon uh man
I've been working on trying to get these
features there's a lot of people that's
been like waiting on verse I can't lie
um but I've been trying to get my album
done you know yeah priorities you got to
get your [ __ ] I gotta yeah I gotta get
me I gotta get my stuff done look at my
fans just waiting so I just say how does
that work for you like if someone hits
you for a verse
um let's say someone sent you a song and
it's dog [ __ ]
I tell them it's dog [ __ ] you tell Miss
dog [ __ ] what if they're well actually
no I don't tell Miss dogs what I like
about it first okay it just depends some
people are like yo will you get on this
song if that's the question
I might just say I don't think this is
the one what else you got you know what
I'm saying but if they say hey what do
you think about this song and I think
it's dog [ __ ] like I'm gonna give them
my feedback but um
like if it's like a dog [ __ ] record
right but they're like double your fee
are you still getting on the dog [ __ ] no
no no that's good that's it the brand
Integrity is important yeah not anybody
can just buy a Bryce and Deliver Us
right exactly anybody out of your
hometown that you're a fan of that we'd
like to shine the light on right now
somebody who's yeah I mean with those
names we named earlier Jack I mean other
than all of them I mean like up and
coming people shout out to Mars really
dope singer from Louisville
um
this other kid that my boy Swan showed
me called plot his name's Platinum super
dope
dope voice no
man that's this other kid I forget his
name but uh my boy just sent them to me
recently but I like his stuff he'd be
around Jack so I'm sure I'm sure you'll
hear about him at some point with uh you
and Jack Harlow ever do a joint like
Louisville
Sluggers album that was so [ __ ] corny
I'm sorry maybe a joint out not at all
we plan on doing it um a little while
ago but he caught me in the middle of
depression so like I just wasn't in that
mental space
um to even do that so um I ended up not
going to Atlanta like we originally
planned and um yeah
how do you deal with depression man
because a lot of people they they keep
it inside and then you know they end up
turning to unhealthy [ __ ] some people
like did you go to therapy did you
um for me
I mean played a lot more video games
um but that's what Vlad said on Twitter
that went viral he said people who play
a certain amount of video games like if
you play more than like four hours a day
or something he said it's a form of
depression
um what does he know does he play video
games I don't know what it went viral I
don't know but so you you kind of dived
into the video games a lot more
um yeah yeah that's what I do
um I try to read as much as I can but
like you know other than that
man I just try to get off of the fake
World which is like you know Instagram
and social media disconnect you know
there's a point where I didn't have
Instagram for like five months or
something like that I was just were you
happier when you didn't have I was super
happy yeah because I didn't think about
it or even care you know um then Twitter
like I would keep it on a certain device
so if I ever wanted to use it I had to
go get this device like a laptop
actually and then use my laptop to get
on Twitter you know
um so just like little things like that
to help me not think about certain stuff
but um yeah I think like when you're
in our industry like it's really easy to
kind of like get wrapped up in like
comparing yourself to your peers all the
time right it's like you open your phone
and you like and that somehow that kind
of
[ __ ] with what you think your
self-worth is yeah it does that yeah and
then like you know I can only imagine
you you got this super microphone on
Twitter and IG of people leaving
comments tweeting at you whether it's
good or bad if you see it even if you
don't think you take it in
subconsciously you take that [ __ ] in you
know yeah exactly you know I mean yeah
definitely subconsciously but uh I don't
even care these days it's just funny
like when I see people who just who just
say just the most negative things like I
just like I'll get messages sometimes a
DM a dude just going in going crazy like
yo you fell off so bad I used to be a
fan of you but not anymore and I'll just
be like I love you bro well first of all
you didn't
yeah but like yo you listen man yeah
you're [ __ ] you're Bryson tiller
don't forget it bro no I appreciate it
no but it don't phase me it used to
phase me don't get me wrong it used to
phase me a lot but now I just like I
just let them know that I love him
because like if you're gonna type this
message up and take all this time to
type this mess up you really actually
love me because was that would you say
that you would like you used to like you
used to like really let that [ __ ] get to
you yeah definitely definitely got to me
yeah for sure I think that's like the
gift I think you just got to push
through that [ __ ] man because a lot of
the great artists have gone through that
when you got a [ __ ] classic album
that kicks kicks off your career
[ __ ] Snoop Dogg man that like he'd
put out the dog father and I think 96
his first time was doggy style don't
give a [ __ ] about the dog father because
it wasn't doggy style yeah I just think
you just gotta just keep dropping bro
keep going because are you um are you
Penning stuff for other people or are
you just I'm trying yeah yeah I'm
definitely trying I like doing that it's
easier because like just to be able to
go in the studio and cut a reference
rather than trying to like sit there for
I'm super meticulous so like sit there
for hours and like correct every vocal
that's just annoying yeah I'm sure if
you cut a reference it's like it's like
a super rough so you don't have to work
you're just like hey this is the idea
this idea you go in here you make it
super magic yeah I'm saying what's uh
the last uh project you helped ride on
last project I hope right on
um man it's been a minute Chris Brown's
album royalty that was the last time I
worked on somebody else's stuff I might
be missing somebody
but uh yeah it was a long time ago what
would be your advice because you're
obviously introvert would you say yeah
what would be your advice for somebody
who's also an introvert and and has has
a problem kind of breaking out of their
shell
in terms of maybe like wanting to be in
the music industry or just wanting to
kind of like be in an industry in which
it can be a little bit harder being an
introvert I would say uh you know just
to remember that like if you're
comfortable like you're not not growing
at all so it's just like same [ __ ] with
the gym like you got to be uncomfortable
to like really grow so like you want to
always try to try to stay just beyond
your comfort zone you know I mean if you
realize that you're super comfortable
you're not in the right place then like
just try to like go a little bit take a
couple steps further you know what I
mean there it is
um before we let you go give me your
Mount Rushmore
of r b music somebody just asked me this
so this is going to be easy Usher
Chris Brown
the dream oh only dog pick four four
four okay
and that last person I'm gonna have to
give that to
Frank Ocean
yeah I thought you were gonna go R Kelly
on us
he'd probably be number five yeah he's
number one yeah I'm saying but yeah but
for obvious reasons you know yeah I
would definitely you know you got he got
some gyms I mean he's R Kelly but he's
also R Kelly yeah
chill out I mean he's the greatest R B
artist of my lifetime he also was a
flaming piece of dog [ __ ] as a human
being that doesn't mean I don't listen
to bump and grind you know what I mean
you got to separate can you separate the
art from The Artisan life in general I
can't yeah I'm one of the few people
that can do that a lot I can't for sure
a lot of people can't do that but I'm
just like bro I'll be in my car
sometimes bumping like R the album and
my wife be like what the [ __ ] is wrong
why are you listening to half on a baby
he's talking about a kid I'm like
because I don't know I don't think about
that [ __ ] I think about when I was 14
and I bought this album and like yeah
shout out there's a lot of artists these
that you listen to a Jeffrey Dahmer
album if it was fire nah nah nah cause I
didn't know him first so like if I would
have known like if there was like a
story about like Robert Kelly pissing on
little girls right and I didn't know he
made music they were just like yeah
Robert Kelly and they had a Netflix
series about him and then and then a lot
of people are learning his music through
that was and then 12 Play leaked yeah
I'd be like damn man sucks like you know
yeah I probably wouldn't even listen to
if Jeffrey Dahmer dropped an album like
well he's dead now right but if he
dropped the album today uh
it probably would go gold which is crazy
because people are going to just go
listen but if it was if it was great I
wouldn't care yet Jeffrey Dominic did
you watch the show a little bit of it I
just can't get into that type of [ __ ]
yeah what's what what shows do you get
into uh anime and I don't really watch
too much TV to be honest like I'm more
so like on Twitch like watching my
favorite Gamers just like tight Kill
[ __ ] who are your favorite Gamers nice
wig my boy dog touch
um shout out to Nick Merks you know he
made the switch from Call of Duty we
still plays God but you know he's an
apex you know Apex with it
um shout out to my boy NOCO Puffs shout
out my boy term k47 so that's kind of
like your Netflix is like watching
dude's game yeah that's tight I uh it
sounded weird when you the way you said
it though but yeah well I mean there's a
bar in uh in Burbank
um it's called The Guild I think and if
you go in there it's like a gamer bar
it's very small it's like a hole in the
wall where is it Burbank yeah it's in
Burbank and they have um instead of like
you know when you go to a sports bar or
any bar usually they have like video or
they have like sports on the TV or ESPN
or whatever oh yeah this it's like every
TV is just a different live twitch
stream thus far there's like board games
I'm about to pull up to the so me and my
wife went in there to drink once and I
was like yo is this live it's like yeah
every TV is a different guy playing
right I'm like that's [ __ ] lit that's
crazy hey we gotta stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks our presenting
sponsor here at the bootleg cab podcast
listen Christmas time is approaching
faster than you think I mean we're like
[ __ ] a month and a half away or some
[ __ ] whatever uh get some Odd Socks for
your folks go to oddsoxofficial.com use
the promo code bootleg and you'll save
20 off at checkout the most comfortable
socks in the world that's right
we got some Scarface socks they got WWE
yeah I mean they also got the Cheech and
chongs they also got the Flamin Hots for
you hot Cheeto eating [ __ ] out there my
favorite just the odd Sox Basics they're
just so comfy
literally the most comfortable sock in
the world I'm holding the [ __ ] sock
right now you can save 20 off plus they
got boxers now baby all right go to Odd
Socks official.com promo code bootleg at
checkout save 20 off and support our
family at odd Sox and the podcast at the
same [ __ ] time let's get back to the
interview yo T Grizzly kind of
revolutionizing the whole absolutely you
know absolutely if you ever watching
with his role-playing thing yeah I
watched him a couple times I'll be
tuning in would you ever do the
role-playing thing I would
um you can't break character they kill
you no I understand I'm probably wait
I'll probably wait to the next GTA to do
some role play yeah you know I know that
GTA 5 has like a long life span but uh
yeah I would do that so when you like
watch Apex guys play are you like you're
just like you're entertained by it or
you're like trying to pick up on I'm
like I'm technique that and I'm also
entertained just like people like doctor
too just like you just keep you
entertained the whole time he's talking
[ __ ] funny funny guy you know I mean a
lot of energy you know are you uh
because you kind of chilled out a little
bit on Twitter in terms of playing right
yeah I've been focused on the album yeah
you know
um but I'm back to it for the holidays
I'm about to finish up here I'm in the
studio locked in I'm trying to get it
done so I can get back to the game you
are a big gamer what would you say
since you already answered the r b
question for someone else give me your
top five video games top five videos all
time of all time any console
um Grand Theft Auto like I can't pick
one specific title I just gotta say
Grand Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto as a
franchise
um the first two Apex Legends okay Apex
Legends
um
I mean as much as I hate to say it you
know Call of Duty you know you just
gotta honor you know Call of Duty you
know everybody knows Call of Duty is I
can never get into like
2K anything like that but uh man Far Cry
3.
um Smash Bros Smash Bros for sure
Smash Bros solid huh Metal Gear Solid
that was a PlayStation game PlayStation
right
I really know were you like a Nintendo
guy I know the characters uh no yeah I
was a Nintendo guy yeah Sega you ever
had the Dreamcast uh no I never owned a
Dreamcast but I played it before played
a couple Sonic games or whatever yeah
yeah it was straight so no Super Mario
yeah yeah I play Super Mario play Zelda
on the switch Yeah Ocarina of Time on
Nintendo 64. that's the one yeah 64
one's the one
but the Ocarina of Time was that yeah
that one was good I think that was the
gold cartridge yep yeah that [ __ ] and
then my favorite uh Mario is Mario 64.
even though I know that one likes the
one on Super Nintendo the most but I
think Mario 64 was crazy no I loved that
one too that was the one I got the most
memories with for sure and GoldenEye on
64 was [ __ ] oh yeah it's classic as
well yeah you get that gold gun yup you
[ __ ] them one-hitters it's been a
minute I played it recently it wasn't as
yeah it didn't age well you know they
tried to bring it back I think like a
couple of consoles ago
and I sought it out and I played it and
I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] was not that
tight it was it was that [ __ ] and it was
uh do you remember they came out with a
game called Perfect Dark I'm in Perfect
Dark yeah and Perfect Dark was kind of
like the same type of maps as golden eye
but like in this like other world sci-fi
yeah and yeah those games did not age
the best because now you have Call of
Duty but if they did like a golden eye
like but just use the whole Call of Duty
engine it could be fire
it was like you had a Beretta an AK like
these guns on these games now these
things are [ __ ] insane yeah golden
eye feels more like a party game to me
now these days it's not really a game
everyone's hanging out everybody's
Hangouts yeah I got a 64 we could hook
up it's not competitive at all I'm sure
there was some competitiveness we could
play what was that one crash crash
bandicoots on Playstation what was the
uh band what was the Banjo and Kazooie
yes with the bear yeah I just played out
a lot too you ever played Glover man no
but yeah what about Earthworm Jim yes of
course okay all right so you're a gamer
the South Park game on 64.
you had to pissy snowballs right it was
so fire yeah I love that game and I'm
gonna bring that back for sure Nitro the
NWO versus WCW Wrestling oh okay yeah
that's classic yeah 64. I was more into
no mercy
yeah no 64 at some heat it's crazy
because there was like two like when I
was a kid I didn't own a 64 but my best
friend had one I had the PlayStation so
I'd like the Best of Both Worlds so when
he come to spend the night being 64 over
we get it popping I would have like
metal gear solid and
you know [ __ ] twisted metal and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] metal classic great
game yeah yeah listen man um new music
coming soon the singles out right now uh
the daily singles going crazy
uh hopefully we'll get the album in the
next three or four months yes sir
putting them samples oh yeah yeah a lot
of samples on the album no not that many
just just enough yeah um anything else
that you got going on you want to plug
ah man that's it that's it that's it go
subscribe on your Twitch yeah go
subscribe to Twitch Godzilla
g-a-w-d-t-i-l-l-a and then also you know
you should probably try to get some sort
of like a partnership with these Apex
[ __ ] you've been you love the game so
much we work yeah we they let me to play
test all the time what is that EA Sports
um respawn and EA respawn but they let
me play they let me play test New
Legends like really three seasons you
already tapped in yeah yeah I'm tapped
in yeah yeah I think you might be the
biggest Apex fan in in music absolutely
because everybody else who comes up here
post Malone think he might be a big Apex
fan of me but he's not who's better and
I'm better what you guys play each other
no I've never played them but you don't
want to he don't want it with me post
Malone you don't want it with me
Brothers we get a challenge going
absolutely because you know he'll [ __ ]
you let's get in the range yeah I don't
drink beer till this one yeah beers for
who for what
I ain't gonna say it just say it just
say it yeah you stick the beer pong beer
is four huh hey it's from post Malone
that ain't for Bryson tiller no beer at
all I don't drink beer what about a
Seltzer I don't even like seltzers you
won't drink a white cloth oh okay if I
have a white cloth
and a Corona next to each other and I
had to pick which one you picking up
I'll probably pick up the corona just
because you know they got more history
in this world what are we talking about
I don't know
for historical purposes
respect respect Corona with white Cloud9
see I drink White Cloud and people say
it's because
um like it's like wow I'm a [ __ ] you're
a [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] drink you know
what I'm saying some real [ __ ] and I'm
like nah bro I'm trying to work on my
figure it's only batteries there's no
sugar in there you know I mean no carbs
you're drinking Corona it's like 230
calories I mean anyway we'll look
appreciate you pulling up man absolutely
Bryson tiller my guy look forward to the
new music my slow